berlino
[Risate]
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi poi ci merlino vedrà la
nuova arrivata la sua sorellina le equa
nel suo cadavere da qui vi faremo vedere
meglio perché dobbiamo mettere tanti
declinio tante cose al nostro cameretta
mi raccomando per introdurre due animali
chiedete sempre consiglio al vostro
veterinario
lasciate un mi piace per vedere altri
video con la gattina lascia che mi piace
adesso
eccoli qua chi gioca ecco la crisi e
vitale con il mio borghino ora è
concentrata sul pane per scritta
mangiando dei pezzi di pane e con la
cena di canina in acqua sta cercando con
un giochino che gli ho dato
stai giocando con la cuccetta nick quale
comprate questo mini tiragraffi però
anche se è un mitra capi ancora troppo
grande per lei
guardate se state pensando che quella
funzione un po troppo grande per lei è
perché quella era una cuccia di berlino
che stranamente non ha distrutto ancora
la parola a
berlino sta guardando la cartina
[Musica]
berlino è un po confuso sta pensando lo
è
ma è quella
che lei se n'è accorta si è accorta di
berlino
ma li frega niente di berlino berlino
imprese la stava osservando il molto
interessato
chiedendo a vita lei ma che cos'è quella
linea vuoto in cui ha vinto
invece coraggiosissima
[Musica]
marlies da tre tranquillo
lei gioca e se ne frega proprio di tutto
[Musica]
e così fra la siamo nell'altra finestra
e quelli na
adesso della casina
[Risate]
cielo berlino
berlino cosa vuoi dire con quella
smorfia
berlino la faccia un po strana è
tranquillissima non ne fa paura per
niente
merlino stava pensando che se questa
creatura microscopica
[Risate]
fernando il vetro berlino fare smorfie
no berlino non si prende quella zampa
ciao
[Musica]
le pecore negli importanti di berlino
mentre berlino fa le smorfie
[Risate]
[Musica]
e ora sta mangiando qualche forchetta è
finito perché ma mette anche le zampe
nella ciotola forse perché il proprio
piccolino mi piace costa ciotola con
orecchie in forma di gatto
[Musica]
[Risate]
abbiamo fatto un po paura
[Musica]
merlino quella cuccia è un po troppo
piccola per te adesso sei diventato
grande e ormai
sei grande e per quella bush abeti che
non ci stai più e non te ne frega niente
l'importante rubarla circe
nel frattempo si osserva marino
bravu merlino berline è diventato sempre
più tranquillo piano piano sta iniziando
ad accettare che è una nuba sorellina
gatto vero berlino
anche lei piano piano sta iniziando ad
accettare che ha un fratello maggiore
gigantesco vero piccola è contenta del
tuo fratello maggiore cani gigante
e terlizzi contento della tua sorellina
piano piano vi metterete grandi amici
spero vero piccola
[Musica]
nel rino che gigante sta sul tappetino
piccolo centro invece circe che è
piccolina significano gigante
io sempre tutto con la febbre di
carcere
anche berlino si gira
eccoli qua che kay
burley ma sembra ancora più grande in
confronto alla piccolina no
lasciate un mi piace per
i
nemici amici
eccoli qua ma intanto al vento perché la
piccolina si sta tormentando
[Musica]